we are in the middle of a global hundred
year pandemic the highest unemployment
since 1948 which is the first year that
unemployment was tracked under the
modern system the largest nationwide
protests that we've seen in a very long
time these over police brutality and one
of the highest numbers of horrifying
police brutality incidents that this
country has seen in such a short period
of time in decades and Donald Trump set
a new record for himself sending out 200
tweets and retweets in a single day on
Friday the president cannot lead and
instead he's tweeting from behind his
bunker fact base which track this
tweeted we're wrapping the day at 200
tweets for Donald Trump most for the
account ever period at 468 tweets it's
the most in a week for Trump during his
presidency and 74 tweets between 8:00
and 9:00 a.m. the most in an hour ever
as you can see there if you're looking
at the chart along with me June 5th
surpassing January 22nd with 200 total
tweets and retweets the most of any data
in Donald Trump's presidency Donald
Trump is now tweeting by the way from
behind 2 miles of fencing and barricades
much of it installed over the last week
as bunker boy as many are calling him
further isolates himself from reality so
there are about five or six different
relevant layers here first of all I'm
not President of the United States I
just have this show I don't have time to
tweet nearly 200 times in a day on a day
where I tweet a lot where I feel like I
probably tweeted too much today I might
tweet 15 times maybe if I do a bunch of
retweets maybe 20 times and and I'm not
President of the United States that's
the first story secondly this day Friday
included 74 tweets in an hour between
8:00 and 9:00 a.m. Eastern Time that is
more than a tweet per hour
a tweet per minute for an entire hour
that is an unhealthy level of social
media use which raises further questions
on its own number three again we're in
the middle of a global hundred year
pandemic highest unemployment since 1948
a huge nationwide protests huge police
brutality issues and Donald Trump sets a
record for himself tweeting and
retweeting 200 times in a single day
that doesn't make sense we need a leader
who can lead and do things now some of
you will say well Trump can't lead so
we're better off with him just sitting
around tweeting but the tweets are
actually doing damage it's not like the
tweets are neutral he's still doing
damage by tweeting number four Trump
just got done attacking Twitter and he's
using it more than ever
why not get away from Twitter if Twitter
is treating him so terribly because he
simply can't and that gets us to the
clinical aspects of this I spoke to a
couple of mental health professionals
over the weekend and they all had a
similar version of the same thing to say
which is essentially that Donald Trump's
behavior as we now see it on Twitter is
compulsive and obsessive and it's a sort
of decompensation of sorts his behavior
is the type of behavior that you know if
your coworker at Best Buy is behaving
this way if your coworker at an
accounting firm is behaving this way
you'd probably go and talk to HR and say
something's not right here it's it's
manic behavior its compulsive behavior
you might have some kind of an
intervention there might be a
psychiatric evaluation done at a certain
point that's the type of behavior that
we're seeing from Donald Trump now one
last thing you might have noticed that I
didn't go through and read individual
tweets of Donald Trump during this
segment and there's no shortage of
tweets that I could have read we are
past the significance of any one of
Donald Trump's tweets in general now if
Donald Trump tweets something that
specifically newsworthy or actionable if
it relates to some new policy that his
administration is going to be rolling
out if it's a direct attack on an ally
if there's some kind of particular
relevance I will tell you what the
content of Trump's tweets
is but what happened on Friday 200
tweets and retweets
it's just erratic behavior and I don't
want to glorify or lend credence to any
one message that Trump sent by actually
reading the tweets you know it was a
combination of lies and smears and
attacks and bragging self-congratulation
retweeting right-wing trash and
conspiracy theories that's what it was
that's the summary the individual tweets
really were irrelevant they didn't
communicate any particular policy they
were mostly smears of other people so I
am NOT going to give them more
credibility or attention than they need
other than to point out 200 tweets in a
day is bonkers and this is the President
of the United States that is where we
will leave it and certainly if Trump
does actually tweet something relevant
to policy I will tell you what it is
fear not one of our sponsors is privacy
calm they're giving you five dollars
when you sign up for their completely
free service at privacy calm slash
Pakman I've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a lifesaver
and here's how it works takes just a
couple of minutes to set up anytime you
buy something online or on the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to twelve of these virtual
credit cards a month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this it means you're not going to
be charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling komban
who you are you keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft and it's
free there's no catch whatsoever but if
you want privacy also offers a $10 a
month plan that gives you one percent
cashback and lets you create 36 credit
cards a month and a $25 a month plan
tailored more for small businesses where
you can create 60 card numbers a month
and much more but definitely go ahead
and at least get started with the free
plan you'll protect your financial info
companies can't charge you unexpectedly
and like I said you'll get $5 to spend
when you sign up at privacy calm /
Pakman